very much believe that they should it's
an important component and we mustn't
let that slip as a certain amount of
feeling there's a financial crisis can
we really afford we have to because we
have a very connected world what what's
happening in other parts of the world
will ultimately affect us unless you
have social stability so it is in the
outcome document of this summit that
there must be a recommitment to the 0.7
percent of GDP which is actually not a
great amount and given the potential of
being able to have a safer and more
balanced world we also know now that the
way in which we're living our lives
based on carbon in the rich parts of the
world is undermining development of the
poorest parts and there's a commitment
that was made in Copenhagen for an
additional 30 billion dollars a year
over the next three years to help the
poorest and most vulnerable countries I
want to see that money as yet I don't
see any new money being committed by
countries and even though there's a
financial crisis we can actually find
the ability and then we need governments
the poor countries to have a real sense
of their responsibility to govern on
behalf of their people
we very much understand the stress and
the worry and the day-to-day concerns of
people who have terrible mortgage
problems who are behind on our payments
who and know that they have problems of
school fees or university fees for the
young people etc and it's the same in
the modern Ireland we're going through a
very tough time in many countries in
Europe and elsewhere but we have to see
the connections in our world I mean look
at a country that has become what we
call now a failed state pretty well
Somalia you have pirates out on the open
seas from Somalia you have a danger of
terrorists being able to group where
there is no law and order and find ways
of attacking and add elsewhere in the
world we are much more interconnected
than we have ever been it's in our total
interests to help to create middle
classes in the developing countries then
they will buy American goods they will
want to trade to the prophet of everyone
and so I think it's it's hard when
you're really wondering how you're going
to meet the commitments for next month
and real worries about about food as
that woman has said but in fact I think
any kind of sense of political
leadership now has to move in the
direction of understanding the
interconnections between our world and
we will not have peace and security if
we do not have fairer bounces because
we're not staying at the same population
level we're going to go up from just
under seven billion people today to over
nine billion and by 2050 that's the
largest increase in population will ever
seen and many of them are in very poor
countries so for stability for our own
generation but particularly for our
children and grandchildren we have to
have this sense of an interconnected
world
I still firmly believe we need to keep
the commitments to development aid but I
also agree with an increasing number of
African leaders and others who say and
we want to bring ourselves out of
poverty we want fairer trade rules we
want some subsidies removed that
disadvantaged us and when we're trying
to compete on cotton or sugar or etc and
and I think that we need to have more
emphasis on access to energy for the
poorest one of the things that has
helped poor countries greatly is the
mobile phone that was the private sector
creating a market in the poor countries
and the mobile phone you know it
attracts markets it transfers money it
does health surveillance it you can do
education on it it's wonderful but there
are 1.6 billion people have no access to
electricity in our 21st century that's
not acceptable if you give energy to the
poorest they will be able to be more
productive and there is that sense that
age shouldn't be sort of kind of and we
look after your needs and not make the
poor productive many of us think that we
have to have much more emphasis on
decent work as part of the whole
approach including by the private sector
the companies that are operating like
coca-cola or other companies in
developing countries most more and more
look at their whole value chain how do
we create more jobs its jobs that take
people out of poverty
I'm very aware because
moving back to Ireland but these are
really very difficult times indeed we've
had the property bubble we've had the
misjudgments to say the least and the
pain and a real sense at the moment of
anger about the unfairness and the role
of the banks and the role of the
property dealers who were most caught up
in that bubble and I'm very glad to be
going back to Ireland I'm really very
happy about it because I want to connect
again with an Ireland that has to
actually find the courage and the
motivation moving forward to try and
engage our very bright young people I'm
going to be linked with the two
universities and Dublin and and really
anybody who's working on climate issues
and we're going to be working to promote
the idea of climate justice I'd like
Ireland to be the go-to place on climate
just as a bridge between the developed
world going into the renewable energies
and necessarily having measures of
mitigation but also the need to transfer
good green technologies no carbon
technologies to the poorest so that they
can develop they have a right to
development and Ireland has a very good
history and tradition of development aid
and began with priests and nuns and
pioneering in the poorest parts of the
world and some of them are still there
and then very good NGOs and Irish age
itself the government and program is
very well regarded as i know in
developing countries because it's very
focused on the poorest and most
vulnerable in a very sustainable way so
I want to try and help to work with
those on the ground to rekindle I think
a sense of real pride and purpose in
Ireland I'm on this issue of climate
justice
I've no doubt it will take a bit of time
but we have a great advantage of size we
have a very bright population there's a
lot of research that has gone on and
there is a sense of community again
maybe during the Celtic Tiger people got
very selfish and now we have more sense
of community I'm hearing that Irish
Gaelic word Mel meaning linked to the
other the spirit of metal metal
communities people in small towns and
villages actually looking after those
who are most hard-hit and you know
there's a human element coming back in
and a community sense and and I do hope
that we will continue to put great
emphasis on education and on our young
people because that's the way we will
turn around fastest but I have every
confidence and we've been in hard times
before we just need to accept that there
was a foolishness and a stupidity and
selfishness and that some people are
feeling pain who didn't have that
responsibility which is provoking a lot
of anger and we need to be as fair as
possible in how we move forward
I think they have certainly changed and
are no longer at all the way that the
United States was perceived at the very
beginning of this century in the year
2000 say and that's reflected in the g20
and other and developments there should
be reformed the Security Council the
Security Council does not reflect the
power balance and economic balance in
our world today and so we need a more
urgent reform than we did because we
recognize at the same time the united
states are still a very very powerful
player and i think there is a wisdom
that the United States reengage again in
these alliances and partnerships that
have been spoken about by the Obama
administration I do believe that that's
the way for the United States to go